it's so funny because years ago when you
were on Idol yeah that was a big
surprise that my family presented me and
my brother with that we would go and see
the show yeah and I'll never forget I
was sitting in the audience and my dad
looked at me I was like it's gonna be
you one day we were far up there right
looking down on the stage and it still
felt so massive my dad was like I don't
know to now be sitting here with you on
this oh what a great daddy when we
worked together before I had no idea
your dad was a personal trainer and then
I saw a picture and I was like wow yeah
so do y'all work out all the time we do
yeah I mean that's crazy okay is it cool
to work out with him are you kind of
like dad lay off um that doesn't work
anymore
Oh for a while that that was like you
know that was the excuse daddy
this hurts and he's like okay we'll
change it up and now it's like I go to
him with like certain you know goals
that I want to achieve and he knows what
he has to do to get me there so awesome
know you've a dad that that's really
really cool okay well whatever Hayley
and her dad do it's working I need to
show you this pic we took a while back
at voice knows like what like I used to
be fit like I used to like working out
and then I turned 30 but right like wait
I don't like this
um but does he have you doing like cuz I
worked out a lot and I never got I was
like that like are you doing just like
3,000 crunches a day every day three so
you're joke you know
holy God oh my gosh you'd have to have
like something like wine sitting in
front to keep going under the Sun you
can think of donuts pizza is all right
and that's crazy I was like super hawk I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this